the Black Forest a cultivated landscape
that centuries old nearly every tree was
once planted by human hand but now
people are being told to stay out
baden-wurttemberg state government wants
to establish a national park in the
northern black forest 10,000 hectares of
virgin forest are to be created here
nature is to be left to itself and
access limited for residents and
tourists many are angry yes to a forest
no to a national park resistance is
growing in the affected communities
against their own Minister heading the
push for a return to nature is green
politician Alexander Banda he thinks
people and business should take a
backseat to increased biodiversity how
tourism experts have discussed this and
informed you about it at 150 meetings
the region has had many opportunities to
have it say many don't want a national
park they want their black forest as it
is and say all the Greens want is a
prestige project you talk about an open
process well you're just making fools of
us irate citizens versus nature
protection feelings are running high
small sawmills in particular fear for
their future Alfred Finkbeiner is the
fourth generation of his family to earn
a living from timber until now his
capital has been 80 to 100 year old
black forest fir trees the Fink bynars
see a national park at their doorstep as
a threat why couldn't react I know it's
melville we can't get any wood from a
virgin forest and we have a lot of
healthy trees in the forest here we have
a forest that's being cared for
reforested and managed for generations
shafted the negative influence a
negative consequence is that we have to
transport timber from far away hairpins
and that's going to cost more
material and we can't absorb those costs
these are healing question couldn't
finish dolefully instead of managed
forests conservationists want a real
wilderness their message to politicians
is that a national park offers the best
chance for endangered species they're
putting pressure on the green state
government it wants the national park
and feel supported by a report that says
a park would benefit both animals and
humans the school acton I believe the
report confirms that the National Park
adds value to the regional economy that
it has clear potential for tourism
service industries craft and commerce
into is misleading /strong with anthrax
we take the worries of the sawmill
industry very seriously but the report
shows a very small amount of timber is
involved here on the SEC line in many
ways in the future thousands of trees
would no longer be felled including
those suffering from diseases forestry
scientist Wolfgang ljubka fears that
could provide a veritable feast for
pests in debug week woulda mention the
moment people stop managing the forest
especially no longer taking measures
against bark beetles for instance after
a storm when trees are blown down the
Beatles will multiply massively will
then have much larger areas of dead
trees like the one behind us
a national park full of dead wood
conservationists don't view that as a
fiasco because Deadwood is the best
place for biodiversity yeah a Madonna
concert we expect all sorts of funky to
come back bird species that depend on
structures like these will return and of
course a great number of insects we're
absolutely certain that about a third to
half the species and forests live in
areas where trees are dying or decay
what's a final invited for a paradise of
Deadwood for insects instead of a nice
tidy Black Forest luxury hotel owner
Minaj medaka says pristine nature isn't
enough to attract well-heeled tourists
he thinks a national park with limited
access decaying trees and plenty of
beetles could be a flop for people in
the hotel industry you be other media I
love with that kind of National Park we
wouldn't have any special attractions
where guests would say I have to go
there and see it that's how we get
tourists who stay the night we need
tourists who come and spend three four
five or seven nights and then visit the
National Park as day trippers denied
denied by Gazoo at the finkbiner sawmill
there was no contradiction between
forestry timber and human activity for
111 years the National Park could change
that you have been I in talk I have the
impression there are too few people here
so no one listens to us we need people
looking for recreation not a national
park where they have to keep to the path
and can't stray to the right or the left
Alfred finkbiner is convinced the
northern Black Forest should stay the
way it is amateur landscape cultivated
by humans for humans to enjoy
you